all right so some Mount stuff
okay cuz I've seen like you struggle
with this one a lot of times uh new
people like they they control by
squeezing right which is going to
fatigue you but if he's really squeezing
and you're trying to do elbow knee like
you're like that's it's not going to
work well that's cuz there's too much y
there you got to do something else okay
and another thing that will happen
because you're a good person the only
reason you're here is cuz you're being
assaulted okay and so this person is
trying to assault you they'll probably
posture up so they can punch drop elbows
and what haveen okay also there's like
things that people do like you can make
him posture up so as as I'm coming
around here and I'm attacking his
trachea and he starts to have energy
going up okay there's any number of
reasons but for this stuff uh to work
the Yang energy here is the squeezing
and he's up okay and you want to make
sure that he stays over your hips on
this one and again key there is that
your elbows are in front of his legs at
a young obstruction so here they're in
front of his legs but they're too high
on his leg they're up here and he can
still get a high mount and squeeze up
like that okay
so if he's down if he's up like some way
up there of course you can push him down
and but you have to make sure that you
do the following those elbows are in
some sort of young uh obstruction to him
okay I can't get my elbows down here
without being too vulnerable this isn't
doing anything for me but here I can
feel that I have enough Yong obstruction
so if he tries to go up he can't go up
with his knees okay and he's staying
down got it okay so arms are here and he
squeezing and we're just going to do the
following experiment yeah I can't get
elbow knee Escape but uh by simply
squeeze your legs by simply turning you
get a lot of uh kazushi going okay so
this is stage one just so you feel it
all all you're going to do is turn your
hips over and you see how easy that is
where before someone squeezing is
causing a lot of hell for you okay so
he's there and you just turn your hips
okay that's phase
one all right so in our uh basic
curriculum we we do that hip up one and
uh it's just to understand like it's
opening is when someone's wrapping
around you like that all tight okay so
uh we're going to do a variation on it
all right I'm going to go one hand so I
go one hand on that Center and I'm going
to
turn till he's over and now I can shrimp
out and pull my elbow out
okay so y contestation on the legs I
have anchored
elbows
one turn boom
shrimp pull my elbow out okay now
let's we're going to do that that's pH
two
okay um
again
one
2 3 okay let's try
that all right so right this is all
admin stuff so he's going up to punch me
right and this is how you do how you
would do this in motion okay okay um
but so people can resist a lot more
administratively because you're not
doing in its proper feet but people are
also strong so if you find like I can't
turn this guy okay uh even though I was
using his energy to help me do this is
you can take your feet and you just move
them over to this side move them over
and then this will give you leg leverage
into the turn okay as opposed to your ha
you're like no no no that's not it you
need more energy so you move it over
into the turn shrimp shrimp out okay and
then what we'll do here in phase three
is you're going to just pull that bottom
leg out okay and he's going to try to
get back on but you have you're out of
the uh you now have your guard you have
your palm heel here and you have your
other knee here okay okay so as he tries
to get back on you are going to be
grounding on the elbow so you
push okay if you can't if your ground
Vector can't do it he's pushing you can
always move okay and as you move you now
create more space he moves creates more
space that's when your leg can come
out
okay so
again on I'll do it with the legs this
time my legs come over Boom Out start
looking for that he starts closing I use
his space his movement that he's
generating to go ahead and create the
openings for the Clos going
okay all
right let's
try uh watch the big picture okay okay
so this fight is going to start
rotating you see as as he's starting to
go I'm not going to go go back on come
back on I'm not going to go back to here
and then try to do elbow knee from there
back up I'm going to get out of the way
of his line of attack okay so as he's
going I'm going to turn this FIP to go
on the other side of him he's going to
want to come back so I'm going to turn
it again and go on the other side of him
and take not close guard but this side
scissor here okay which is better for
me right so you have your elbow locks
here does weird things with his arm
wrist locks can open up but this way I'm
not flat again where I started okay so
watch how as he's trying to get
on
I keep
deviating out from under him boom he
comes on I'm going to go to the other
side see I'm on the other side already
he has to push back and that's where I
go to the other side again might as well
keep going to the other side and then
take the side scissor and the elbow
okay careful you're
not out of a training scar going back to
admin closed guard okay
all right here we go